So we're doing something a little different this week. Every, I'm in the studio with every truffman, say hi. Hi. Hi. One of the things about this story in particular is that it's about the process of ideas and how they move through the world, correct? Yeah, exactly. It follows the seed of an idea from one unexpected place to a kind of other unexpected place. And without giving away the whole story, it's an episode that I did in 2017 that has become
所以我们这周要做点不一样的。我正在录音室里和Avery Truffman在一起，打个招呼吧。嗨。嗨。关于这个故事，特别的一点是，它讲述的是创意的产生过程以及它们如何在世界中流转，对吧？是的，没错。它追踪了一个创意从一个意想不到的地方，萌芽并流向另一个意想不到的地方的过程。在不剧透整个故事的前提下，这是我在2017年制作的一期节目，它已经变得
very near and dear to me because of what it's about, because it's about where ideas come from and that's something I think about a lot. But it's also because the story isn't over. It just continues to unfold, like the sequence of inspiration is continuing to unfurl and now in the telling of the story we have become a part of it which is a cryptic way of saying that there are updates so we want to play the story that you did what is called the pool in the stream i was so long ago uh yeah yes i think it's called the pool in the stream we We're going to play the pool in the stream, and then we're going to tell you a whole nether story about how this story went out in the world and changed the world a little bit more.
对我来说非常亲切和珍贵，因为它讲述的内容，因为它关乎创意的来源，这是我经常思考的问题。但这也是因为故事并没有结束。它还在继续展开，就像灵感的序列在不断延伸，而在讲述这个故事的过程中，我们也成为了它的一部分。这是一种隐晦的说法，意思是现在有了后续进展，所以我们想播放你当年制作的那期节目，叫《溪流中的水潭》，那是很久以前的事了，呃，是的，我想它叫《溪流中的水潭》。我们要播放《溪流中的水潭》，然后我们会告诉你另一个完整的故事，关于这个故事是如何传播到世界各地，并让世界发生了一点点改变。
Yeah. Check it out. This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When people ask us where we get our stories from, the answer is usually hard to pen down. It could be something one of us noticed walking around, or something a friend mentioned, or some forwarded link on Twitter. It's nearly impossible to say where inspiration comes from, in any art form.
好的。来看看吧。这里是《99%隐形》。我是Roman Mars。当人们问我们从哪里获得故事灵感时，答案通常很难确定。它可能是我们某个人在走路时注意到的事情，或者是朋友提到的某件事，又或者是Twitter上转发的某个链接。在任何艺术形式中，几乎不可能说清楚灵感来自何处。
It's a long way from the seed of an idea to its execution. The brilliant architect, Oliver Alto, put it very well in an extended metaphor about a fish in a stream. He wrote, Architecture and its details are in some way all part of biology. Perhaps they are, for instance, like some big salmon or trout. They're not born fully grown. They're not even born in the sea or water where they normally live.
从一个创意的萌芽到最终实现，还有很长的路要走。杰出的建筑师阿尔瓦·阿尔托（Alvar Aalto）用一个关于溪流中鱼的扩展隐喻很好地表达了这一点。他写道：“建筑及其细节在某种程度上都是生物学的一部分。也许它们就像某种大马哈鱼或鳟鱼。它们并非生来就完全成熟。它们甚至不是出生在它们通常居住的海洋或水域中。”
They are born hundreds of miles away from their home grounds, where the rivers narrow to tiny streams. Just as it takes time for us to spec a fish pond to mature into a fully grown fish, so we need time for everything that develops and crystallizes in our world of ideas. This is a story about one idea born hundreds of miles away in a far off stream, an idea that would travel
它们出生在离家园数百英里远的地方，那里河流汇聚成细小的溪流。正如鱼卵发育成一条完全成熟的鱼需要时间一样，我们世界中所有发展和结晶的事物也需要时间。这是一个关于一个创意在数百英里外的一条遥远溪流中诞生的故事，一个将会旅行的故事
from northern Europe to southern California, where it would take on a whole new life before making its way back again. It's a story in three parts by producer Avery Troubleman. Part one, California. Two skaters in a plaza are confronted by a guard. Can't skate here?
从北欧到南加州，在那里它将获得全新的生命，然后再回到原点。这是一个由制作人Avery Truffman带来的三部分故事。第一部分，加利福尼亚。广场上的两名滑板手被一名保安拦住。不能在这里滑板？
Oh man, it looks so good. Just one broken leg, please. It's kind of a pity that skateboarding is banned in so many places because skateboarders appreciate the small details of architecture more than anyone. They recognize the quality of concrete, the grain of wood, the incline of a structure. They recognize the way a landscape flows. My name is Jake Phelps, I'm the editor of Thrash from Magazine from San Francisco, California, born in raised. Yeah, what do you got?
天哪，看起来太棒了。请让我摔断一条腿吧。滑板运动在这么多地方被禁止真是一种遗憾，因为滑板手比任何人都更能欣赏建筑的微小细节。他们能识别混凝土的质量、木材的纹理、结构的坡度。他们能识别景观流动的方向。我叫Jake Phelps，我是来自加利福尼亚州旧金山的《Thrasher》杂志的编辑，土生土长。是的，你有什么发现？
Thrash is a skateboarding magazine that skaters call the Bible. Visiting its headquarters is kind of surreal. It's like if you went to a skate park and yelled out to all the punks, Hey, you guys want to go hang out in an office? They're all there, and sneakers and beanie caps, slumped behind monitors like caged animals You can tell they'd rather be skating. I'm a skater. I dress like a skater These are the costumes I've ever run in all of my life. I don't wear a fucking Louis Vuitton clothes
《Thrasher》是一本滑板杂志，滑板手们称之为“圣经”。参观它的总部感觉有点超现实。就像你走进一个滑板公园，对着所有的朋克大喊：“嘿，你们想去办公室待着吗？”他们都在那里，穿着运动鞋和无檐小便帽，像被关在笼子里的动物一样瘫在显示器后面。你能看出他们宁愿去滑板。我是一名滑板手。我的穿着就像个滑板手。这些是我这辈子穿过的最舒服的衣服。我才不穿那些该死的路易威登衣服。
If you did it, I mean I wear sneakers and This is the way it is. We're you tillitarian. We skate. It's the greatest thing in the world. Jake Phelps is 55 years old. Tattoos, all over his arms. Big, thick glasses of his face and close-cropped gray hair. He blatantly hits on me in the interview and invites me to his punk band's show over the weekend. I don't think he'd mind that I told you that.
如果你做了，我是说我穿运动鞋，这就是现状。我们是实用主义者。我们滑板。这是世界上最棒的事情。Jake Phelps今年55岁。双臂上满是纹身。脸上戴着一副厚重的大眼镜，留着修剪整齐的灰发。他在采访中公然调戏我，并邀请我周末去参加他朋克乐队的演出。我想他不会介意我告诉你们这些。
Skateboarding never says no. Girlfriends, jobs, life. People always say, no, I can't do that. I've been doing this for 40 years. You can't tell me I can't do it. Fuck you. Say the fuck away from me. skateboarding is, you know, it's like an extension of me.
滑板运动从不说不。女朋友、工作、生活。人们总是说：“不，我做不到。”我已经做了40年了。你不能告诉我我做不到。去你的。离我远点。滑板运动，你知道，它就像是我身体的延伸。
It's like it's an art. It's something that you have to understand. So where does the artistry come in? It's your whole Jouat of V how you hold yourself. And that Jouat of you, that sort of badass double-may-care attitude that skaters have perfected, that's kind of funny because skateboarding was pretty dorky back when it was just getting started. The very first skateboard was called the skateboard scooter, and it was a scooter. This is Stacey Peralta, skateboarding pioneer and director of the excellent documentary,
它就像是一门艺术。这是你必须去理解的东西。那么艺术性体现在哪里呢？这是你的整体风度，你如何掌控自己。而那种风度，那种滑板手们所完善的、那种玩世不恭的酷劲，这其实挺有趣的，因为滑板运动刚开始的时候其实挺傻的。第一个滑板被称为“滑板滑板车”，它确实就是个滑板车。这是Stacey Peralta，滑板运动的先驱，也是那部优秀纪录片的导演，
Dogtown and Z-Boys, which is all about the birth of modern skateboarding. Stacey says at some point, no one really knows when, but someone knocked the handlebars off the scooter and just rode the board. And probably emulated surfing, and so what happened was skateboarding had a very, very brief appearance in 1964 and 65. Skateboards were sold in toy stores, and skateboarding briefly became a fad. But then as quickly as it started, it died out again. It was like the hula hoop. It has come and gone.
《狗镇和滑板少年》，讲述了现代滑板运动的诞生。Stacey说在某个时刻，没人知道具体是什么时候，有人把滑板车的车把拆掉，只踩着板子滑。可能是在模仿冲浪，于是滑板运动在1964年和1965年有过非常非常短暂的出现。滑板在玩具店里出售，滑板运动短暂地成为了一种时尚。但它消失得和出现时一样快。就像呼啦圈一样。它来过又走了。
As the skateboard fad was receding into the distance, Stacey was growing up in Venice Beach, California. It was the early 70s, and Stacey was a little surf rat with long blonde hair. And when the waves were bad in the middle of the day, he and his friends wanted something to do. What we really wanted to do was emulate surfing. They wanted to surf on land, and they discovered old skateboards.
当滑板热潮逐渐消退时，Stacey正在加利福尼亚州的威尼斯海滩长大。那是70年代初，Stacey是个留着金色长发的冲浪小屁孩。当白天浪况不好时，他和朋友们想找点事做。我们真正想做的是模仿冲浪。他们想在陆地上冲浪，于是他们发现了旧滑板。
One of my friends, his older brothers, had skateboarded in the very early 60s and they had two skateboards left in their garage that they never touched. So we started riding those boards. Those early skateboards had these hard clunky wheels made out of clay or steel. So you'd eat dirt if you ran over a pebble or a penny on the ground. And that meant tricks had to be very simple, like I can stand up straight, or I can balance on the tip of the board. Maybe a wheelie.
我的一个朋友，他的哥哥们在60年代初玩过滑板，他们的车库里还剩下两个滑板，从来没动过。所以我们开始骑那些板子。那些早期的滑板有着用粘土或钢制成的坚硬笨重的轮子。所以如果你压到地上的鹅卵石或硬币，你就会摔个狗吃屎。这意味着技巧必须非常简单，比如我可以站直，或者我可以平衡在板子的尖端。也许是个翘头。
You could just kind of scoot back and forth on a flat, smooth surface. It's flat land tricks. That's basically what you could do. Stacey was really young, like maybe seven years old. But you can remember skating for the first time, even with those big clunky clay wheels, little Stacey found a blissful stillness. It was so profound that from that point forward,
你只能在平坦、光滑的表面上滑来滑去。那是平地技巧。基本上你只能做这些。Stacey当时真的很小，可能才七岁。但他能记得第一次滑板的情景，即使踩着那些笨重的粘土轮子，小Stacey也找到了一种幸福的宁静。这种感觉太深刻了，从那时起，
I needed to get back on that board and find that stillness because I'm more relaxed when I stand on a skateboard than I am when I walk. But Stacey and his friends were discovering skateboards while the rest of the country was forgetting them. Stacey had that old board heat on Earth than his friends garage. But after I wore that out,
我需要回到那块板子上，找回那种宁静，因为我站在滑板上时比走路时更放松。但Stacey和他的朋友们在发现滑板时，全国其他地方却正在遗忘它。Stacey有那块在朋友车库里找到的旧板子。但在我把它磨损之后，
there was no more boards to see, you know, that I could buy in stores. It just, you couldn't buy a skateboard back then. So instead, Stacey and his friends would go to a thrift store and buy a pair of roller skates, which had clay or metal or hard plastic wheels. And maybe Stacy would take the left skate and his friend would take the right skate and they'd cut the bases off the wheels and put them on a plank of wood and then ride that
再也没有板子可以看了，你知道，我能在商店里买到的。那时候你根本买不到滑板。所以，Stacey和他的朋友们会去旧货店买一双旱冰鞋，上面有粘土、金属或硬塑料轮子。也许Stacey会拿走左边的溜冰鞋，他的朋友拿走右边的，他们把轮子的底座拆下来，装在一块木板上，然后骑着它
back and forth and back and forth and back and forth and back and forth for hours. And the hours that we spent doing it would be equivalent to a kid today, jumping up and down for eight hours on a pogo stick. Every single day, seven days a week, and you'd probably go, geez, maybe we should tell this kid that there's no future in this. Then in the early 70s, an invention comes along that would revolutionize skateboarding,
来来回回，来来回回，来来回回，来来回回几个小时。我们花在上面的时间，相当于现在的孩子每天在弹簧高跷上跳八个小时。每一天，一周七天，你可能会说：“天哪，也许我们应该告诉这个孩子，这没前途。”然后在70年代初，一项发明出现了，它将彻底改变滑板运动，
the year-thane wheel. This soft plastic wheel had more give to it and held the ground, unlike those clunky, dangerous clay wheels that preceded it. These soft wheels were intended for roller skaters at the dawn of the roller disco era, but a small company called Creative Yerathans
聚氨酯轮。这种软塑料轮比之前那些笨重、危险的粘土轮更有弹性，抓地力更好。这些软轮原本是为旱冰鞋设计的，正值旱冰迪斯科时代初期，但一家名为Creative Urethanes的小公司
began producing Yerathane wheels specifically for scapegoats. Put the board together back there and then up with the wheels on up here. The wheels were sold at surf shops since there were no skate shops and they were advertised in surfer magazine. 58.46 altogether.
开始专门生产用于滑板的聚氨酯轮。把板子组装好，然后把轮子装上去。这些轮子在冲浪店出售，因为当时没有滑板店，它们在《冲浪者》杂志上做广告。总共58.46美元。
And in the summer of 1974, sales of your-thane wheels went gangbusters. Suddenly we had a wheel that could grip and it could roll over bumps and little rocks and it allowed us to attack terrain that previously were not we were not able to attack. Now they could skate all surfaces. Greater Los Angeles was theirs to claim. And so that meant school yards that meant in garages, city buildings, it was any place. Anything was rideable, but none of this was designed for us, none of it. These young kids were jumping fences and trespassing, breaking things on search of new surfaces to ride.
1974年的夏天，聚氨酯轮的销量火爆。突然间，我们有了一种可以抓地、可以滚过颠簸和小石头的轮子，它让我们能够挑战以前无法挑战的地形。现在他们可以在所有表面上滑行。大洛杉矶地区任他们驰骋。这意味着学校操场、车库、市政建筑，任何地方都可以。任何东西都可以滑，但这些都不是为我们设计的，一点也不是。这些年轻人翻越围栏，擅闯私人领地，破坏东西，只为寻找新的滑行表面。
They were reinterpreting the city around them, finding the beauty and the pavement and the concrete of their world. And then, in the mid 70s, there was a drought in California. In Southern California, the driest part of the state. There have been dozens of brushfires, some have been big and expensive, and more fires are threatened, as Californians crave for rain, but right now, the workers say not as expected.
他们重新诠释了周围的城市，在他们世界的路面和混凝土中发现了美。然后，在70年代中期，加利福尼亚发生了一场干旱。在南加州，该州最干燥的地区。发生了几十起灌木丛火灾，有些规模很大，损失惨重，更多的火灾还在威胁着，加州人渴望降雨，但目前，气象人员说情况并不乐观。
The drought was so bad in the 70s that the water company ran billboard ads that encouraged couples to shower together to save water. And to further save water, people didn't fill up their swimming pools. And in Los Angeles, there are a lot of swimming pools, and they're very distinctive looking. What we had in Los Angeles is we had the big, beautiful, voluptuous shapes that you did not see anywhere else in the world that you find in Los Angeles, except in very, very, very, very small quantities.
70年代的干旱非常严重，自来水公司甚至打出广告，鼓励夫妻一起洗澡以节约用水。为了进一步节水，人们不再填满他们的游泳池。在洛杉矶，有很多游泳池，它们看起来非常有特色。我们在洛杉矶拥有的是那些你在世界其他任何地方都看不到的、巨大、美丽、丰满的形状，除了极少数极少数的情况。
The pools of Los Angeles are shaped like peanuts, like keyholes, like kidney beans. They have these curved, undulating edges. They are paved in even smooth concrete with gently varying rounded depths that slope back up to the lip. And during the drought in the 70s, they were all empty. They were perfect. They just were so beautifully conceived and designed and we fell in love with the shapes.
洛杉矶的游泳池形状像花生、像钥匙孔、像腰果。它们有弯曲、起伏的边缘。它们铺着平整光滑的混凝土，有着轻微变化的圆形深度，一直倾斜到边缘。在70年代的干旱期间，它们全都干涸了。它们太完美了。它们的设计构思如此精美，我们爱上了这些形状。
Stacey and his friends would hunt for pools. They'd find a house under construction or patrol the fancy parts of town where they knew they'd find the most sumptuous, luxurious pools. Tony! They'd hopped a fence, they'd break in. We'll bail, we'll lift it up to you guys. If there's a little bit of old dirty water in the pool,
Stacey和他的朋友们会去寻找游泳池。他们会找到正在施工的房子，或者在城里的高档区域巡逻，因为他们知道那里会有最奢华、最豪华的游泳池。Tony！他们会翻过围栏，闯进去。我们会把板子递给你们。如果池子里有一点点脏水，
they'd drain it out themselves with buckets they brought or trash cans they found, or eventually they'd bring an industrial vacuum along with them. And then they would skate up and down in the pool. They'd go so fast they could go up the wall. They could skate like they were surfing away. When we finally got to ride swimming pools and feel weightless, like going up a vertical wall, weightlessness is pretty extraordinary. Skateboarding became a form of choreography,
他们会用带来的水桶或找到的垃圾桶自己把水排干，或者最终他们会带上一台工业真空吸尘器。然后他们会在池子里滑来滑去。他们滑得太快了，甚至可以冲上池壁。他们滑起来就像在冲浪一样。当我们最终能骑着滑板在游泳池里滑行，感受到失重感，就像冲上垂直的墙壁一样，那种失重感非常非凡。滑板运动变成了一种编舞，
where you're trying to do as much as possible in the limited space of the pool, and look graceful while doing it. Here we were a bunch of scruffy kids, and here we are riding in backyard pools, and we know what we're doing is beautiful, and we get to feel beautiful. And this beauty attracted attention.
你试图在有限的池内空间里做尽可能多的动作，并在此过程中看起来优雅。我们是一群衣衫褴褛的孩子，我们在后院的游泳池里滑行，我们知道我们所做的是美丽的，我们能感受到这种美。而这种美吸引了人们的注意。
Back in the first wave of skateboarding in the early 60s, there had been a magazine called Simply Skateboarder. It went out of business when the skateboarding fad died out. But in the mid 70s, the magazine came back and it featured Stacey and his friends riding in backyard pools. At that point, every kid in America and all over the world wanted to get inside a swimming pool. That was it.
早在60年代初的第一波滑板热潮中，曾有一本名为《滑板手》的杂志。当滑板热潮消退时，它就倒闭了。但在70年代中期，这本杂志又回来了，它刊登了Stacey和他的朋友们在后院游泳池里滑行的照片。那时，美国乃至全世界的每个孩子都想进入游泳池。就是这样。
That was the Holy Grail. And so the drought really acted as a wonderful midwife to the skateboarding revolution. Eventually, Stacey and the other skateboarders got so good at pool skating, they were able to skate up over the edge of the pool. They could kind of jump up in the air and maybe do a spin or something before dropping back into the pool. And these aerial tricks led to another genre of skateboarding. So style became less important and extreme maneuvers became more important.
那是圣杯。所以干旱确实成为了滑板革命的绝佳助产士。最终，Stacey和其他滑板手在池中滑行的技术变得如此高超，他们能够滑出池边。他们可以在空中跳跃，也许在落回池子之前做个旋转之类的动作。这些空中技巧引出了滑板运动的另一个流派。于是风格变得不那么重要，而极限动作变得更加重要。
Aerial tricks paved the way for the X games, half pipes and Tony Hawk. This whole chapter of the sport where skaters were trying to vault themselves really, really high up in the air. And that can all be traced back to the rounded, biomorphic pools of Los Angeles. The ones shaped like peanuts and keyholes and kidney beans. L.A. was the backyard pool mecca, but not just the backyard pool mecca, but not just the backyard pool mecca, the properly beautifully designed backyard pool.
空中技巧为X运动会、U型池和Tony Hawk铺平了道路。这是这项运动的整个篇章，滑板手们试图将自己弹射到非常非常高的地方。而这一切都可以追溯到洛杉矶那些圆形的、生物形态的游泳池。那些形状像花生、钥匙孔和腰果的池子。洛杉矶是后院游泳池的麦加，不仅是后院游泳池的麦加，而且是设计得恰到好处、美轮美奂的后院游泳池的麦加。
And I don't know of any place in the world that has that proliferation of that kind of voluptuous, sensuous design. The pools of Southern California and their proliferation led to the proliferation of skating. More people are skateboarding now than ever. It's a $7 billion industry. Goddamn. That's Jake Phelps at Thrashar again. People are skating pools every day. People are skating right now.
我不知道世界上还有哪个地方拥有如此多那种丰满、感性的设计。南加州的游泳池及其普及导致了滑板运动的普及。现在滑板的人比以往任何时候都多。这是一个价值70亿美元的产业。该死。那是《Thrasher》的Jake Phelps。人们每天都在池子里滑板。人们现在就在滑。
People just, somebody just broke their arm in a pool right now. Trust me. And the pools of California bring us to our next chapter. Do you know the story about where the bean shaped pool comes from? The bean shape, what's the bean shape? But the right, Henny Kinney? Is that what it's called? Well, yeah, they're called bean shaped.
有人刚刚在池子里摔断了胳膊。相信我。而加州的游泳池把我们带到了下一个篇章。你知道豆形游泳池的由来吗？豆形，什么是豆形？是那个，Henny Kinney？是叫这个吗？嗯，是的，它们被称为豆形。
I don't know. Well, obviously it would be some esoteric design to someone's backyard. Well, Jake Phelps doesn't have to be all like that about it, but he's right. It starts with one esoteric design in someone's backyard. But it might be the most famous private backyard in 20th century American history. Part 2.
我不知道。好吧，显然这会是某人后院里某种深奥的设计。好吧，Jake Phelps没必要表现得那么刻薄，但他说的对。它始于某人后院里一个深奥的设计。但这可能是20世纪美国历史上最著名的私人后院。第二部分。
Sonoma On top of a remote hill in Sonoma County in Northern California, at the end of a long curvy dirt road, the car pulls into a driveway. Three small dogs rush out to meet a retro from the car. Hi. So you got a little lost. Sorry, we overshot it a little bit. A little bit, sounds like it.
索诺玛。在北加州索诺玛县一个偏远山顶上，在一条漫长弯曲的土路尽头，车子开进了一条车道。三只小狗冲出来迎接车里的人。嗨。所以你们迷路了一点点。抱歉，我们稍微开过头了。稍微一点点，听起来是这样。
Justin Faggiole and Sandy Dunnell are the owners and caretakers of this property, which is known as the Dunnell Garden. It's really famous in the world of landscape architecture. But if you want to visit it, it's kind of a challenge. You can't find it on Google Maps. That address is wrong. And there aren't any public listings or sites with contact information for it.
Justin Faggiole和Sandy Dunnell是这处房产的所有者和看护人，这里被称为Dunnell花园。它在景观建筑界非常有名。但如果你想参观它，那是个挑战。你在谷歌地图上找不到它。那个地址是错的。而且没有任何公共列表或网站提供它的联系信息。
Because it's just a private home. A modest sized retro-modern looking house on a hill. It was Sandy's parents' place. I grew up on the Dunnell Ranch property born in 1951 the youngest of three children. The Donnell Garden was planted in 1948 and it was revolutionary at the time. Traditional gardens of the early 20th century had been more or less symmetrical rows of different kinds of flowers. They were kind of like plant museums. May be accented with a geometric hedge or a fruit tree. The Donald Garden is nothing like that. It's mostly lawn. The lawn is a unifying feature. It meanders through everything and it becomes the river, the green
因为它只是一个私人住宅。山上一座中等大小的复古现代风格房子。那是Sandy父母的地方。我在Dunnell牧场长大，1951年出生，是三个孩子中最小的一个。Dunnell花园建于1948年，在当时是革命性的。20世纪初的传统花园或多或少是不同种类花卉的对称排列。它们就像植物博物馆。也许点缀着几何形状的树篱或果树。Dunnell花园完全不是那样。它大部分是草坪。草坪是一个统一的特征。它蜿蜒穿过一切，成为河流，那条绿色的
river that goes from space to space. The garden looks like a sea of clean cut grass with floating islands of tropical plant clusters or groups of rocks and a few ancient oak trees, and there are large swaths of concrete and a big wooden deck. From above, the garden is almost like a mateese collage, an arrangement of abstract shapes on a green grass canvas. And the most distinctive shape, of course, is the pool. Oh my God! Here's the object of your search. A kidney pool. This, from what we know, was the first kidney shaped pool in California.
河流从一个空间流向另一个空间。花园看起来像一片修剪整齐的草海，漂浮着热带植物群岛或岩石群，还有几棵古老的橡树，有大片的混凝土和巨大的木制露台。从上方看，花园几乎就像马蒂斯的拼贴画，在绿色草地画布上抽象形状的排列。而最独特的形状，当然是游泳池。天哪！这就是你们要找的东西。肾形池。据我们所知，这是加州第一个肾形游泳池。
It's every bit as beautiful as I thought, actually. It is bright, pristine, electric blue. And in the center of the pool is an abstract sculpture by Adeline Kent, which has two holes through it, one above water, and one below. And you can swim through the holes in the center of the pool is an abstract sculpture by Adeline Kent, which has two holes through it One above water and one below and you can swim through the holes in the sculpture like a dolphin and it's insanely fun I know because I tried it The pool overlooks acres of dusty ranching property You can hear the hum of cars on a racetrack often the distance and you can see the The pool overlooks acres of dusty ranching property.
它确实和我预想的一样美。它是明亮、纯净、电光蓝色的。在游泳池的中心是一个由Adeline Kent创作的抽象雕塑，上面有两个洞，一个在水面上，一个在水下。你可以游过这些洞。在游泳池的中心是一个由Adeline Kent创作的抽象雕塑，上面有两个洞，一个在水面上，一个在水下。你可以像海豚一样游过雕塑里的洞，这太好玩了。我知道，因为我试过。游泳池俯瞰着数英亩尘土飞扬的牧场。你可以听到远处赛道上汽车的嗡嗡声，你可以看到
You can hear the hum of cars on a racetrack, often the distance, and you can see the Hodgepodge skyline of San Francisco, looming haisily beyond it. I couldn't help but think that a stator would kill to drain this pool. It's beautiful. Wow. It's hard to overstate the importance of the Donnell Garden to both formal landscape architecture and everyday American backyards. Sandy Donnell told me that a picture of the garden was Indian cyclopedia Britannica under landscape architecture. The property also helped create what we think of as the modern suburban backyard with the lawn, the deck, and the pool.
你可以听到远处赛道上汽车的嗡嗡声，你可以看到旧金山杂乱的天际线，在远处朦胧地隐现。我不禁想到，一个滑板手会为了排干这个池子而拼命。它太美了。哇。很难夸大Dunnell花园对正式景观建筑和日常美国后院的重要性。Sandy Dunnell告诉我，花园的照片被收录在《大英百科全书》的景观建筑条目下。这处房产还帮助创造了我们所认为的现代郊区后院，包括草坪、露台和游泳池。
I would guess with the exception possibly a Versailles, that the Denel Garden was probably the most published garden, at least in the 20th century. Architectural historian Mark Tribe. The Denel Garden was designed by Thomas Church, a landscape architect who wanted to create outdoor spaces that people would use and love. The title of Thomas Church's book
我猜，除了凡尔赛宫之外，Dunnell花园可能是20世纪出版次数最多的花园。建筑历史学家Mark Tribe说。Dunnell花园是由Thomas Church设计的，他是一位景观建筑师，想要创造人们会使用和喜爱的户外空间。Thomas Church的书名
was actually, Gardens are for people. In Gardens are for people, he asked hypothetical clients, how much do you really like to garden? If you don't want to garden, you know, the paving makes a lot of sense. Church said that gardens didn't necessarily have to be those traditional rows and rows of flowers. And this was a revelation for modern families like the Donnells. necessarily have to be those traditional rows and rows of flowers.
实际上是《花园是为人们准备的》。在《花园是为人们准备的》中，他问假设的客户：“你到底有多喜欢园艺？”如果你不想做园艺，你知道，铺装路面很有意义。Church说，花园不一定非要是那些传统的花卉行。这对像Dunnell一家这样的现代家庭来说是一个启示。
And this was a revelation for modern families like the Donnells. They wanted a place for parties and relaxing and lounging. They wanted their yard to be a piece of functional art that their kids and dogs could clamber on. The Donnell Garden became the epitome of outdoor California lifestyle. Throughout the 1950s, lifestyle magazines, like Sunset and House Beautiful, featured the Donnell Garden on their covers. In many ways, it became the icon
这对像Dunnell一家这样的现代家庭来说是一个启示。他们想要一个聚会、放松和休息的地方。他们希望他们的院子成为一件功能性的艺术品，他们的孩子和狗可以在上面攀爬。Dunnell花园成为了加州户外生活方式的缩影。在整个50年代，像《Sunset》和《House Beautiful》这样的生活方式杂志都在封面上刊登了Dunnell花园。在许多方面，它成为了标志，
certainly of American modern landscape architecture. A lot of it being, of course, is why we're here for the swimming pool. As images of the Donnell Garden began to spread, newly minted suburbanites across Southern California began to imitate it. And West Coast landscape architects were inspired by its creative use of paving and lawn, and its beautiful, biomorphic, curvy pool.
当然是美国现代景观建筑的标志。当然，很大程度上这就是我们为什么在这里的原因，为了游泳池。随着Dunnell花园的图像开始传播，南加州各地新晋的郊区居民开始模仿它。西海岸的景观建筑师们受到它对铺装和草坪的创造性使用，以及它美丽的、生物形态的、弯曲的游泳池的启发。
The pool inspired thousands of imitators, and eventually thousands of young skaters in Southern California. Now we can't know for sure exactly where Thomas Church came up with the idea of using the original kidney shape. Retro boomerang shapes were appearing in everything from fine art to mass-produced textiles and for mykatebles. By 1947, these shapes were everywhere. You know, they were on everything and everywhere.
这个游泳池启发了成千上万的模仿者，最终启发了南加州成千上万的年轻滑板手。现在我们无法确定Thomas Church究竟是从哪里想出使用最初肾形形状的想法的。复古的回旋镖形状出现在从美术到大规模生产的纺织品和Formica桌面的所有东西上。到1947年，这些形状无处不在。你知道，它们出现在所有东西上，无处不在。
So it's really hard to say. But there is a really interesting and widespread theory about where church got his inspiration for the kidney pool. Skateboarding came to my neighborhood like, at the end of 1980s, we got a little bit of like magazines and videos coming from the California scene. Part three, Finland. A redrofenment actually went to Finland. How did you get those videos of the skaters in California?
所以真的很难说。但关于Church从哪里获得肾形池灵感，有一个非常有趣且广泛流传的理论。滑板运动在80年代末来到我的社区，我们从加州场景中得到了一些杂志和视频。第三部分，芬兰。Avery Truffman实际上去了芬兰。你是怎么得到那些加州滑板手视频的？
The first ones came when some was dead, went to a business trip to states, and then they brought back some videos. Yannisario grew up in Finland, watching videos of California skaters, and he caught the bug in a big way. He started skateboarding and then became sponsored and started skating in cities all over the world. Through skateboarding, I fell in love
第一批视频是当有人去美国出差时带回来的。Janne Saario在芬兰长大，看着加州滑板手的视频，他深深地迷上了这项运动。他开始滑板，然后获得了赞助，并开始在世界各地的城市滑板。通过滑板，我爱上了
with architecture and design. Yana went to university and studied architecture in part to have more control over the spaces he's skated. I'll just like sneak into that business and I won't tell anyone that I'm a skater and just make sure that the hand rail is skated or the stairs have a good materials and curves. In architecture school, Yana distinctly remembers a lecture he heard about the origins of the kidney pool. There was a professor coming from California and she was having a lecture and talking about
建筑和设计。Janne上了大学，学习建筑，部分原因是为了对他滑板的空间有更多的控制权。我会偷偷溜进那个建筑，我不会告诉任何人我是个滑板手，只是确保扶手可以滑，或者楼梯有好的材料和曲线。在建筑学院，Janne清楚地记得他听过的一场关于肾形池起源的讲座。有一位来自加州的教授在做讲座，谈论
the journal garden. I think she was saying that it's the mother of all kidney pools. But that didn't seem right to Yana. He knew about another kidney pool. It's actually a grandmother of all pools. It's in Finland, in the middle of Finland. And it was designed by an architect and designer named Alvar Alto. Alvar Alto's work and his life was exceptional in that sense that he was a pioneer in a cross-disciplinary thinking and design.
Dunnell花园。我想她说它是所有肾形池之母。但这在Janne看来不太对。他知道另一个肾形池。它实际上是所有池子的祖母。它在芬兰，在芬兰中部。它是由一位名叫阿尔瓦·阿尔托（Alvar Aalto）的建筑师和设计师设计的。阿尔瓦·阿尔托的作品和生活在某种意义上是卓越的，因为他是跨学科思维和设计的先驱。
This is Anti Alava, an architect and vice president of Alto University, which is named after Alvar Alto. He designed a marvelous furniture, and also he had a flourishing business. Alvar Alto is the man in Finland. There are busts of him everywhere. He designed a lot of the public and government buildings and meeting halls in Helsinki. And Alvar Alto's furniture is in, I kid you not, almost every single building. Almost every home has something designed by Alvar Alto.
这是Anti Alava，一位建筑师，也是阿尔托大学的副校长，该大学以阿尔瓦·阿尔托命名。他设计了精美的家具，而且他还有着蓬勃发展的业务。阿尔瓦·阿尔托是芬兰的大人物。到处都有他的半身像。他设计了赫尔辛基的许多公共和政府建筑以及会议厅。而且阿尔瓦·阿尔托的家具，我不骗你，几乎在每一栋建筑里。几乎每个家庭都有阿尔瓦·阿尔托设计的东西。
Alto is beloved and venerated beyond Finland too. Frank Lloyd Wright loved Alto and he hated other architects. Frank Gary also cites Alto as one of the only other architects that he admires. Alvar Alto was an architect's architect and his work helped create a unique finish aesthetic which was an important part of developing a unique finish identity because Finland is a relatively young country. Okay Finland was first for about 500 years part of Sweden and then for 100 years part of Russia. There are some movie theaters in California that are older than Finland. It was only in 1917 that Finland became independent.
阿尔托在芬兰之外也备受爱戴和尊崇。弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特（Frank Lloyd Wright）喜欢阿尔托，但他讨厌其他建筑师。弗兰克·盖里（Frank Gehry）也称阿尔托是他钦佩的仅有的几位建筑师之一。阿尔瓦·阿尔托是建筑师中的建筑师，他的作品有助于创造一种独特的芬兰美学，这是发展独特芬兰身份的重要组成部分，因为芬兰是一个相对年轻的国家。好吧，芬兰先是作为瑞典的一部分约500年，然后作为俄罗斯的一部分100年。加州有些电影院比芬兰还要古老。直到1917年芬兰才独立。
Before that, it was Russian, and it looks like it. The architecture in downtown Helsinki is unexpectedly regal and intimidating. The buildings line the streets like towering pastel cakes with white ornate trim. Helsinki has stood in for Moscow and Lenin grad in a number of films. And at the end of 19th century, it became very important to create our own national identity and try to get independent. Finland wanted to step away from Soviet romanticism, especially because the rest of Europe was experimenting with a new approach called functionalism.
在此之前，它是俄罗斯的一部分，看起来也确实如此。赫尔辛基市中心的建筑出奇地庄严且令人生畏。建筑像高耸的粉彩蛋糕一样排列在街道两旁，带有白色的华丽装饰。赫尔辛基在许多电影中都曾作为莫斯科和列宁格勒的替身。在19世纪末，创造我们自己的民族身份并试图获得独立变得非常重要。芬兰想要摆脱苏联的浪漫主义，特别是考虑到欧洲其他地区正在尝试一种称为功能主义的新方法。
Functionalism was a reaction to the dirty, nasty, polluted cities of the 19th century, which were loaded down with extra trim and ornaments and statues, and functionalism was like an architectural cleanse. Functionalism wanted to be healthy, there was lots of sunlight, air betweenally, it's wanted to be healthy. There was a lot of sunlight here between buildings. It was fresh. Think of the sharp lines and steel and metal of the German Bauhaus or the pristine concrete of Lecobusier. Functionalism is clean, geometric, stark, spacious, modern, and a little sterile. So, Alta was influenced by functionalist ideas, but wanted to humanize them.
功能主义是对19世纪肮脏、恶心、污染严重的城市的一种反应，那些城市充斥着额外的装饰、饰品和雕像，而功能主义就像是一次建筑清洗。功能主义想要健康，建筑之间有大量的阳光和空气，它想要健康。这里建筑之间有很多阳光。它很清新。想想德国包豪斯（Bauhaus）的锐利线条和钢材，或者勒·柯布西耶（Le Corbusier）纯净的混凝土。功能主义是干净、几何、严谨、宽敞、现代，而且有点无菌。所以，阿尔托受到功能主义思想的影响，但想要使它们人性化。
Adopting this kind of international influences and making his own versions of that. Alta's architecture was crisp and functional, but a little more natural and organic. And he did this in part by using a lot of wood. He made wood behave in ways it hadn't before. Bending and gluing in a new way. This is Jonas Moundberg, architect and art historian with the Alto Foundation.
采用这种国际影响并制作他自己的版本。阿尔托的建筑既干练又实用，但更自然、更有机。他通过大量使用木材在一定程度上做到了这一点。他让木材以以前没有过的方式表现。以一种新的方式弯曲和粘合。这是Jonas Moundberg，阿尔托基金会的建筑师和艺术史学家。
Where are we? Can you describe where we are? Sure, this is Aldo's own house. And also the office was located here. Jonas showed me the legs of some chairs and stools Alto had made and talked about Alto's patented method for bending and curving wood. This method allowed Alto to make curvy molds
我们在哪里？你能描述一下我们在哪里吗？当然，这是阿尔托自己的房子。办公室也设在这里。Jonas给我看了阿尔托制作的一些椅子和凳子的腿，并谈到了阿尔托获得专利的弯曲木材的方法。这种方法使阿尔托能够制作弯曲的模具，
to make these wavy glass vases that he became famous for. It's blown in that timber mold. We get a bit different and new shapes for it. Curves made their way into Alto's stairways and walls, and he made curving partitions to break up space, and he used rounded tiles and undulating countertops. So it was a fair to say a lot of the curves he just made because he could,
来制作他成名的那些波浪形玻璃花瓶。它是用那个木模吹制的。我们得到了稍微不同和新的形状。曲线进入了阿尔托的楼梯和墙壁，他制作了弯曲的隔断来分割空间，他使用了圆形的瓷砖和起伏的台面。所以可以说，很多曲线他只是因为能做就做了，
like he figured out how to do it and he was just getting. Probably, yes, yes. And he probably wanted those, he wanted the buildings to be kind of something that you can't really predict. So when an art collector and lumber herish named Marie Goulixson asked Alta to design her country home, the Villa Maria,
就像他弄清楚了怎么做，然后他就做了。可能吧，是的，是的。而且他可能想要那些，他想要建筑成为某种你无法真正预测的东西。所以当一位名叫Marie Gullichsen的艺术收藏家和木材女继承人请阿尔托设计她的乡村住宅，即玛利亚别墅（Villa Mairea）时，
Alta wanted to keep it very stark and clean, but also very friendly and natural. And we don't have there like any expensive material. Just timber in the floor, some red brick on the wall. We don't have any material that would be posh. But of course in Finland, if you're going to have a country villa, you're going to have a sauna. It's part of our finish way of spending the time
阿尔托想让它保持非常严谨和干净，但也非常友好和自然。我们那里没有任何昂贵的材料。地板上只有木材，墙上有一些红砖。我们没有任何时髦的材料。但当然在芬兰，如果你要有一个乡村别墅，你得有一个桑拿房。这是我们芬兰人消磨时间的方式，
in the rural countryside. It's a sauna culture. And if you're going to have a sauna, you need a pool to cool off in. And Alvar Altow made a pool with a very curious shape. Well, it's the kind of reform. It's a bit of a, well, maybe a sock, you see it? It is, it is.
在乡村田野里。这是桑拿文化。如果你要有一个桑拿房，你需要一个游泳池来降温。阿尔瓦·阿尔托制作了一个形状非常奇特的游泳池。嗯，这是一种回旋镖形状。有点像，嗯，也许是一只袜子，你看到了吗？是的，是的。
It's kind of a sock with curvy ends. Hmm. The story goes that Thomas Church, the California landscape architecture designed the Denel Garden, went on a trip to Finland with his wife Betsy in 1937. Somehow they found out the address of Alvar Altos' home in studio and got themselves there. And they just knocked on the door. Architectural historian Mark Trivian.
它有点像一只带有弯曲末端的袜子。嗯。故事是这样的，设计了Dunnell花园的加州景观建筑师Thomas Church在1937年和他的妻子Betsy去芬兰旅行。不知何故，他们找到了阿尔瓦·阿尔托在赫尔辛基的家和工作室的地址，并找了过去。他们只是敲了敲门。建筑历史学家Mark Tribe说。
When the story goes, Altos came out in his bathroom and invited them in. And so Thomas Church and his wife Betsy and Alvar Alto and his first wife, I know, all really hit her off. And they got to be good friends. And it is quite possibly the case that Alto's design for the Villa Myria and its sock-shaped pool were displayed in his studio when Thomas Church was visiting. Myder was finished in 39, but they were there in 37. Maybe it was on the drawing boards,
故事是这样的，阿尔托穿着浴袍出来，邀请他们进去。于是Thomas Church和他的妻子Betsy，以及阿尔瓦·阿尔托和他的第一任妻子Aino，都非常投缘。他们成了好朋友。而且很有可能，阿尔托为玛利亚别墅设计的袜子形状的游泳池在Thomas Church访问时就展示在他的工作室里。玛利亚别墅于39年完工，但他们在37年就在那里了。也许它在绘图板上，
and maybe there was no pool at the time. I mean, we just don't know. There's no way to verify it, but that's the story Architects tell. If there's a book about the Don Elgarten, it's probably going to have a mention of the Villa Myria. Yeah, the story goes that Thomas Church went back home, then it was 1948 when the Donnell Garden was made,
也许当时还没有游泳池。我的意思是，我们只是不知道。没有办法核实，但这就是建筑师们讲述的故事。如果有一本关于Dunnell花园的书，它很可能会提到玛利亚别墅。是的，故事是Thomas Church回国了，然后是1948年Dunnell花园建成，
so almost 10 years after. And then the Donnell Garden pool becomes famous, appearing on magazine covers and inspiring hundreds of imitators across Southern California. And these hundreds of curvy biomorphic pools get emptied out in the drought in the 1970s and inspire a whole new skate culture. And that culture inspired kids around the world like Yana to take up skateboarding.
所以几乎在10年后。然后Dunnell花园的游泳池变得出名，出现在杂志封面上，并启发了南加州各地的数百名模仿者。而这数百个弯曲的生物形态游泳池在70年代的干旱中被排干，并启发了一种全新的滑板文化。而那种文化启发了像Janne这样的世界各地的孩子开始滑板。
And skateboarding inspired Yana to become an architect. And now he has a specialty. Yeah, I'm the only skate park designer in Finland. He designs curvaceous pools all over Europe. Pools exclusively for skating. There's one big pool coming to the east side of Helsinki. It's a really nice figure in. And something to be proud of, I think.
而滑板启发了Janne成为一名建筑师。现在他有了专长。是的，我是芬兰唯一的滑板公园设计师。他在欧洲各地设计弯曲的游泳池。专门用于滑板的游泳池。赫尔辛基东区正在建设一个大池子。这是一个非常好的形状。我认为这是值得骄傲的事情。
When Janis says he's proud, he means that public skate parks and skate pools should be a source of civic pride, especially in Finland, where Janne likes to tease. Modern skateboarding began. I kind of use it as a joke when we're out with skate park builders, they're usually from states or Canada and I'm trying to claim skateboarding for having its roots in Finland. Some say that Alvar Alta's pool at the Villa Myria was inspired by the soft bends in a finished lake. Or maybe Alta was just excited about his ability to make wavy forms
当Janne说他感到自豪时，他的意思是公共滑板公园和滑板池应该成为公民自豪感的来源，特别是在芬兰，Janne喜欢开玩笑说。现代滑板运动开始了。当我和滑板公园建造者在一起时，我经常把它当作一个笑话，他们通常来自美国或加拿大，而我试图声称滑板运动起源于芬兰。有人说阿尔瓦·阿尔托在玛利亚别墅的游泳池灵感来自于芬兰湖泊的柔和弯曲。或者也许阿尔托只是对制作波浪形形式的能力感到兴奋，
since that kind of became his signature and his furniture and homewares. Or who knows, maybe he was inspired by some other curvy pools, somewhere else in the world that we don't know about. Alto didn't like to talk about his inspiration, he didn't write too much about it either. Alto only talked about the birth of his ideas in an extended metaphor, about a fish in a stream. Architecture in its details are in some way all part of biology. Perhaps they are, for instance, like some big salmon or trout. They're not born fully grown. They're not even born in the sea or water where they normally live.
因为这在某种程度上成为了他的标志，以及他的家具和家居用品。或者谁知道呢，也许他受到了世界上其他地方我们不知道的其他弯曲游泳池的启发。阿尔托不喜欢谈论他的灵感，他也没有写太多关于它的东西。阿尔托只在关于溪流中鱼的扩展隐喻中谈到了他创意的诞生。建筑及其细节在某种程度上都是生物学的一部分。也许它们就像某种大马哈鱼或鳟鱼。它们并非生来就完全成熟。它们甚至不是出生在它们通常居住的海洋或水域中。
They're born hundreds of miles away from their home grounds, where the river is narrow to tiny streams. Just as it takes time for us back of fish spawn to mature into a fully grown fish, so we need time for everything that develops and crystallizes in our world of ideas. Go farther up, push! Cheers! You better believe that. Jake Phelps, the editor of Thrasher magazine, passed away in March of 2019. So we're back in the present. I'm in the studio with Avery. And so what is the update on this story? Yeah, as we said before, this is a story about the unexpected connections between things. And the thing is,
它们出生在离家园数百英里远的地方，那里河流汇聚成细小的溪流。正如鱼卵发育成一条完全成熟的鱼需要时间一样，我们世界中所有发展和结晶的事物也需要时间。走得更远，推！干杯！你最好相信这一点。《Thrasher》杂志的编辑Jake Phelps于2019年3月去世。所以我们回到了现在。我正在录音室里和Avery在一起。那么这个故事的后续进展是什么？是的，正如我们之前所说，这是一个关于事物之间意想不到联系的故事。而问题是，
the story seems to just keep going on and on even two years after it came out. Because I was just talking to this guy, Jonathan Neshe, he's a furniture, lighting, and exhibition designer, and he listened to the pool in the stream when it came out back in 2017. My youngest son, who was then 12, can't this idea for my oldest son, who escaped boards, who was then 14, he should start on a senior project now of a new skate park, which I thought was like, what a crazy idea, you know, they're not even in high school yet. It's actually a great idea for a senior project though. There was already a skate park in their town, which was built as a senior project back in 1999. And so Jonathan poked around
这个故事似乎在它发布两年后还在继续。因为我刚才在和乔纳森·内舍（Jonathan Neshe）交谈，他是一位家具、照明和展览设计师，他在2017年节目刚播出时就听了关于滑板公园的那一期。我当时12岁的小儿子为我当时14岁的大儿子想出了这个主意，他当时在玩滑板，他应该现在就开始做一个关于新滑板公园的毕业设计，我觉得这真是个疯狂的主意，你知道，他们甚至还没上高中。不过，这确实是一个很好的毕业设计点子。他们镇上已经有一个滑板公园了，那是1999年作为毕业设计建造的。于是乔纳森四处打听了一下，
a bit and looked into what was going on with this skate park. And found out that a committee was just about to form through the parks department for a renovation of a skate park in Columbus. Columbus, Indiana. That's where Jonathan lives. Yeah. You know about Columbus, Indiana. Famed Columbus, Indiana. Because you have a show about architecture and design. Yeah. It's this unexpected epicenter of modern design. Yeah, it's amazing. Exactly. It's the small city of 27,000 people, but it's full of soaring, statuesque, modernist buildings by some of the most canonical architects
了解了一下这个滑板公园的情况。结果发现，公园管理部门正准备成立一个委员会，对哥伦布市的一个滑板公园进行翻新。印第安纳州的哥伦布市。那是乔纳森住的地方。是的。你知道印第安纳州的哥伦布市。著名的印第安纳州哥伦布市。因为你有一个关于建筑和设计的节目。是的。它是现代设计意想不到的中心。是的，太棒了。没错。这是一个只有27000人的小城市，但它到处都是由一些最经典的建筑师设计的耸立的、雕塑般的现代主义建筑，
of the 20th century. You would think with 85 significant works of architecture, it would be a high brow place, but it's just so everyday and civic. It's not like the Homes and Columbus Indiana are fancy. The cool thing is it's all the public buildings. It really is every fire station and police station and elementary middle high school junior colleges. They're all done by significant architects Kevin roast to rubber venturi and Paul Ken and you know, book this would be a town full of architecture nerds and useless hipsters like me, but it's very blue collar. It's a working class, but there's a high concentration of engineers because of the automotive fields.
这些建筑师属于20世纪。你可能会认为拥有85件重要建筑作品的地方会是一个高雅的地方，但它却非常日常和市民化。印第安纳州哥伦布市的住宅并不华丽。最酷的是所有的公共建筑。真的，每一个消防站、警察局、小学、中学、高中和初级学院都是由重要的建筑师设计的，比如凯文·罗奇（Kevin Roche）、罗伯特·文丘里（Robert Venturi）和保罗·肯（Paul Kenn）。你知道，人们会认为这是一个充满建筑书呆子和像我这样无用文青的小镇，但它其实非常蓝领。这是一个工人阶级城市，但由于汽车领域的原因，这里聚集了大量的工程师。
And also because of the automotive industry, Columbus is a very diverse town because there are engineers and employees from all over the world. And then the engine, Wink of Columbus, is a corporation called Cummins. It's a Fortune 500 company that designs, manufactures and distributes engines. And they work with the Nissan and John Beer and Dodge. And Cummins started about 100 years ago with this old banking family in Columbus. The family's chauffeur was tinkering and perfecting the diesel engines. His name was Clancy Cummins. Cummins was a farm boy who stopped schooling at eighth grade, but clearly he was a talented mechanic. The wealthy family he worked for and their patriarch, the industrialist Joseph Irwin Miller, bank rolled an engine company, and Clancy Cummins, their chauffeur, became the CEO.
而且由于汽车工业，哥伦布市是一个非常多元化的城镇，因为这里有来自世界各地的工程师和员工。哥伦布市的引擎是一家名为康明斯（Cummins）的公司。这是一家财富500强企业，设计、制造和分销发动机。他们与日产、约翰迪尔和道奇合作。康明斯大约在100年前由哥伦布的一个老银行家族创立。那个家族的司机当时正在摆弄和完善柴油发动机。他的名字叫克兰西·康明斯（Clancy Cummins）。康明斯是一个农家男孩，八年级就辍学了，但他显然是一位天才机械师。他工作的富有家族及其族长、实业家约瑟夫·欧文·米勒（Joseph Irwin Miller）资助了一家发动机公司，而他们的司机克兰西·康明斯成为了首席执行官。
And in the late 30s as a civic gift to the town, both to beautify it and also to attract talent, the industrialist Miller decided to give his little city a beautiful new church. But the fateful thing was who they got to design the church. Allial Sarnin's name came up and that changed the course of the city. So, Allial Sarenin, you know, is a massive deal. When I was in Finland, the two big names that came up over and over again were Allial Sarenin
在30年代末，作为给城镇的一份市民礼物，为了美化城市也为了吸引人才，实业家米勒决定给他的小城市建造一座美丽的新教堂。但关键在于他们请了谁来设计这座教堂。埃列尔·沙里宁（Eliel Saarinen）的名字被提了出来，这改变了这座城市的进程。所以，你知道，埃列尔·沙里宁是一个大人物。当我在芬兰时，反复出现的两个大名字是埃列尔·沙里宁
and Alvar Alto. Right. Like Alvar Alto's reign was postwar, Sarenin was early turn of the last century. And while Alvar Alto did that kind of natural modernism style, Elial Sarenin did these regal nouveau style buildings with stone and copper patina, like he designed the Grand Central Helsinki train station. And then, Elial Sarenin moved to the United States in the 20s and settled in the Midwest. He was a professor at the University of Michigan. And here in the States, Eleol is just as famous for his buildings as he is for his son,
和阿尔瓦·阿尔托（Alvar Aalto）。没错。阿尔瓦·阿尔托的时代是在战后，沙里宁是在上世纪初。虽然阿尔瓦·阿尔托采用了那种自然现代主义风格，但埃列尔·沙里宁设计了这些带有石材和铜绿的庄严的新艺术风格建筑，比如他设计了赫尔辛基中央火车站。后来，埃列尔·沙里宁在20年代移居美国，定居在中西部。他是密歇根大学的教授。在美国，埃列尔作为建筑师的知名度和他儿子一样高，
because he was the father of... Eros, aren't it? Exactly. Like when most Americans say Sarenin, they're talking about Eros. He did the St. Louis Arch, the old TWA terminal at New York's JFK airport. He designed the famous tulip chair,
因为他是……埃罗·沙里宁（Eero Saarinen）的父亲。没错。当大多数美国人提到沙里宁时，他们指的是埃罗。他设计了圣路易斯拱门、纽约肯尼迪机场的老TWA航站楼。他设计了著名的郁金香椅，
made of white plastic and red cushioning. He's huge. He's like a master of the 20th century. And so when Eleo Cerenin built a simple geometric limestone church in 1942 in Columbus, Indiana, Ero Cerenin got roped in. And he worked with his father on the first church and then he did one of his last buildings was North Christian church in 64. Ero also built the conference center in town
由白色塑料和红色坐垫制成。他非常了不起。他就像20世纪的大师。所以当埃列尔·沙里宁于1942年在印第安纳州哥伦布市建造了一座简单的几何形状石灰岩教堂时，埃罗·沙里宁也被拉了进来。他与父亲合作了第一座教堂，然后他设计的最后一批建筑之一是64年的北基督教教堂。埃罗还在镇上建造了会议中心
and a private house for the wealthy Miller family. Like his fingerprints are all over Columbus, Indiana. And then after Arrow passed away, all of the architects in his office went and did work in Columbus, and it spread from there. Like in Columbus, Indiana, I am paid at the library, Edward Charles Bassett of Skidmore, Owings and Merrill, did the City Hall. Columbus basically became an institution.
以及为富有的米勒家族建造了一座私人住宅。他的印记遍布印第安纳州的哥伦布市。在埃罗去世后，他办公室里的所有建筑师都去哥伦布工作，并从那里传播开来。在印第安纳州哥伦布市，我参观了图书馆，斯基德莫尔、奥因斯和美林建筑设计事务所（SOM）的爱德华·查尔斯·巴塞特（Edward Charles Bassett）设计了市政厅。哥伦布基本上变成了一个建筑机构。
So this is quite incredible to see this, like, this single move of hiring Elil Sarn and the chain of events that happened because of it. Which is also so funny that just like the pool in the stream, like that story starts in Finland. Which brings us back like that story starts in Finland. Yes. Which brings us back to the skate park in town. So, as you can imagine, it's kind of intimidating to build something in a town full of wildly impressive architecture. But Jonathan wanted to be part of the process.
所以看到这一切真是令人难以置信，比如聘请埃列尔·沙里宁这一单一举措所引发的一系列连锁反应。这也很搞笑，就像那个滑板公园的故事一样，故事是从芬兰开始的。这让我们回到了……故事是从芬兰开始的。是的。这让我们回到了镇上的滑板公园。所以，你可以想象，在一个充满令人惊叹的建筑的城镇里建造东西是有点令人生畏的。但乔纳森想参与这个过程。
I got on the committee with a lot of sessions about what this is going to be. Like, we recreate this exactly the way it was. And then your podcast came. I just looked it up July 4th, 17. And then I reached out to Yane July 27th. So Jonathan reached out to Yane Sario, the finished skate park designer in the story, because of our episode. Wow. Yane became the designer the finished skate park designer in the story because of our episode.
我加入了委员会，进行了很多关于这将会是什么样子的会议。比如，我们是否要完全按照原来的样子重建它。然后你的播客就出现了。我查了一下，是17年7月4日。然后我在7月27日联系了亚内（Yane）。所以乔纳森因为我们的节目联系了故事中的芬兰滑板公园设计师亚内·萨里奥（Yane Sario）。哇。亚内成为了故事中那个芬兰滑板公园的设计师，因为我们的节目。
Wow. Yana became the designer of the skate park in Columbus. He's been incredible to work with and a true master at his craft and pairing him with a local skate park builder where everyone on the team skateboards, the owners of the company's skateboard, and their trolling concrete. It's like there's just so much heart and passion. Then we'll post pictures of the skate park so listeners can see it, but it's totally beautiful. The park, the park almost looks like ocean waves.
哇。亚内成为了哥伦布滑板公园的设计师。与他合作真是太棒了，他是一位真正的大师，将他与当地的滑板公园建造者配对，团队中的每个人都玩滑板，公司的老板也玩滑板，他们用混凝土施工。感觉这里面有太多的心血和热情。我们会发布滑板公园的照片，让听众可以看到，它真的很美。公园，公园看起来几乎像海浪一样。
People love it. It's just been absolutely incredible. The skaters, the BMXers, the guys that ride the scooters, they all love it. Yesterday, nearly 50 people there. And it's so gratifying to Jonathan, especially because his oldest son was also on the committee, so it was kind of a family effort. And now they all get to enjoy the fruits of their labor together.
人们喜欢它。这绝对是令人难以置信的。滑板手、小轮车手、骑滑板车的人，他们都喜欢它。昨天，那里有近50人。这对乔纳森来说非常令人欣慰，尤其是因为他大儿子也在委员会里，所以这算是一次家庭努力。现在他们都可以一起享受劳动的成果了。
Actually, the skate park has convinced Jonathan to pick up his BMX bike again. And it gives us a great place to spend time with my kids. They're 14 and 16. I don't have a whole lot of years left of them being in the house. What a kind of fun way to have them see an idea and then see the steps that it takes to realize an idea. Which of course is what the story is all about. Where ideas come from and where they travel. I mean, who knows who will go to this park in the years to come and discover new friends or new community or new passion and move the chain of inspiration forward from there?
事实上，滑板公园说服了乔纳森重新骑上了他的小轮车。它为我们提供了一个与孩子们共度时光的好地方。他们分别是14岁和16岁。他们在家里的时间不多了。这真是一种有趣的方式，让他们看到一个想法，然后看到实现这个想法所需的步骤。当然，这正是这个故事的全部意义所在。想法来自哪里，它们又流向何方。我的意思是，谁知道未来几年会有谁来到这个公园，发现新朋友、新社区或新激情，并从那里推动灵感的链条向前发展呢？
Of everything that I've been part of this has by far been the most meaningful, just playing a connector, you know. I do know. It's an amazing thing. I feel so lucky to be a part of this story, like making these connections is the best part of my job. Oh, it's so cool. I love it. Me too. And the other thing is, like, we didn't... The story could have gone back even farther. Like, we could have talked about the origins of surfing. And it could have gone forward into the future because film changed when all the escape kids started picking up cameras and they changed the way the tracking shot works in cinema.
在我参与的所有事情中，这绝对是最有意义的，仅仅是扮演一个连接者的角色，你知道。我确实知道。这是一件了不起的事情。我觉得自己很幸运能参与这个故事，建立这些联系是我工作中最好的部分。哦，太酷了。我喜欢它。我也是。另一件事是，我们没有……这个故事本可以追溯到更久远的地方。比如，我们可以谈谈冲浪的起源。它也可以延伸到未来，因为当所有的滑板少年开始拿起摄像机时，电影发生了变化，他们改变了电影中跟踪镜头的工作方式。
Like the story goes off in all these different directions, but the fact that it also manifested in this literal concrete example in Columbus, Indiana is just gorgeous. I love it. That's great. Yeah. Good update.
故事向着所有这些不同的方向发展，但它也以这种具体的混凝土形式在印第安纳州哥伦布市呈现出来，这真是太美了。我喜欢它。太棒了。是的。很好的更新。
The world is better. Thank you, Avery. Thanks, Roman. The 99% invisible was produced this week by Avery Truffleman, edited by Delaney Hall, mixed and tech production by Sheree Fusef, Music by Sean Rial and Melodium. Our senior producer is Katie Mingle Kurt Colstead is the digital director. The rest of staff includes Emmett Fitzgerald, Joe Rosenberg, Vivian Lee, Chris Barubey, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Mars.
世界变得更好了。谢谢你，艾弗里（Avery）。谢谢你，罗曼（Roman）。本周的《99%隐形》（99% Invisible）由艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）制作，德莱尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）编辑，谢里·富塞夫（Sheree Fusef）负责混音和技术制作，音乐由肖恩·里亚尔（Sean Rial）和Melodium创作。我们的高级制作人是凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle），库尔特·科尔斯特德（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。其余工作人员包括埃米特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）、薇薇安·李（Vivian Lee）、克里斯·巴鲁比（Chris Barubey）、索菲亚·克拉茨克（Sophia Klatsker）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。
Since your gratitude this week to Michael Burnett, Mark Rodriguez, Jason Reignman, Chris Funk and Adam Lee, Charles Burnbbaum and the Cultural Landscape Foundation. San Francisco Garden Designer at Gabrielle Cameron, David Lewis and Alta University, and a special shout out to Andrew Norton for sparking this idea and Kelsey Keith for telling us about the Columbus, Indiana connection. Their archival sound was from the Vanderbilt University Archive and the 1978 movie, Skateboard Kings, which you can find on YouTube. Please do yourself a favor and watch Stacey's documentary, Dogtown, and Z-Boys. It is great!
本周感谢迈克尔·伯内特（Michael Burnett）、马克·罗德里格斯（Mark Rodriguez）、杰森·雷恩曼（Jason Reignman）、克里斯·芬克（Chris Funk）和亚当·李（Adam Lee）、查尔斯·伯恩鲍姆（Charles Birnbaum）以及文化景观基金会（Cultural Landscape Foundation）。旧金山花园设计师加布里埃尔·卡梅伦（Gabrielle Cameron）、大卫·刘易斯（David Lewis）和阿尔托大学（Aalto University），特别感谢安德鲁·诺顿（Andrew Norton）激发了这个想法，以及凯尔西·基思（Kelsey Keith）告诉我们关于印第安纳州哥伦布市的联系。档案音频来自范德比尔特大学档案馆和1978年的电影《滑板之王》（Skateboard Kings），你可以在YouTube上找到它。请帮自己一个忙，看看斯泰西（Stacey）的纪录片《狗镇和滑板少年》（Dogtown and Z-Boys）。它太棒了！
We are a project of 91.7K ALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, a fiercely independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find more at radiotopia.fm You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet at me at Roman Mars and the show at 99PI award on Instagram and Reddit too.
我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心美丽的Radio Row制作。《99%隐形》是PRX旗下RadioTopia的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。在radiotopia.fm了解更多信息。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，也可以在Instagram和Reddit上关注该节目@99PI。
But we have all the threads of this story gathered together for you to follow to your heart's content at 99PI.org. Radio til the end. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
但我们在99PI.org上为你收集了所有这些故事的线索，供你尽情探索。广播直到最后。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。